[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'essentiel le magazine
qui reprend toute l'actualité de la
semaine au département tout de suite
l'actualité en chiffres le 6 9 7 4 en
gage 114 nouveaux sapeurs pompiers
volontaires afin de renforcer son
effectif opérationnel
un recrutement qui entre dans le cadre
de la politique de développement du
volontariat
au sein du service départemental
d'incendié et de secours
c'est un geste fort aussi bien pour nous
qui les accueille au et je l'espère pour
eux qu'ils rejoignent la grande famille
des sapeurs pompiers
il faut en partie des 2500 pompiers qui
seront un jour qui feront partie à jour
10 6 et la réunion aujourd'hui nous n'en
sommes pas très loin d'ici deux trois
ans nous sort en 2005 c'est l'objectif
qui nous est assignée une centaine
d'auditeurs de l'institut des hautes
études de défense nationale de la zone
océan indien s'est retrouvé à la villa
du département pour une soirée de gala
une réception qui clôture de session de
formation le 107e cycle jeunes et la
212e session en région ce sont en fait
des personnes qui participent à la prise
en compte des opérations de défense et
de sécurité et donc il ya des sessions
de formation qui sont organisées par des
généraux
et formateurs venus de métropole réunis
sont donc en l'occurrence 55 auditeurs
de tous les milieux civils et militaires
fonctionnaires et et privés et nous
réfléchissons à toutes ces questions
nous leur donnons aussi un aspect de
formation avec trois pôles c'est bien
ensuite des visites où nous allons voir
les unités militaires qui sont sur place
les certaines des installations
industrielles
lorsqu'il y en a c'était la troisième
édition du salon des seniors un rendez
vous entièrement dédié aux 50 ans et
plus qui pendant trois jours ont pu
rencontrer des experts spécialisés dans
le bien-être le trophée du bien vieillir
la réunion a été décerné à la spl avenir
réunion pour le développement de sa
qualité de service et ses innovations
dans l'amélioration de l'habitat pour
les familles les plus modestes en 2017 a
été près de 900 dossiers d'amélioration
de l'habitat et le envisageant de passer
à 1000 dossiers cette année l'esprit est
important c'est de savoir respirer et
dans la réactivité
lc j'avais des situations d'urgence
parce que nous avons mis en place une
régie et cette régie permet justement de
travailler rapidement pour apporter une
réponse à des besoins urgents en faveur
des personnes âgées
et puis je voudrais vous dire aussi que
l'espérer a développé un outil qui
permet à tout le monde de constituer son
dossier d'amélioration de l'habitat sans
avoir à se déplacer d'une plateforme
numérique bien sûr et utilisable par les
familles à nos bras molle pour
constituer leur dossier d'amélioration
de l'habitat
sébastien lecornu secrétaire d'état à la
transition énergétique s'est rendu au
palais de la source pour rencontrer les
élus du département
une visite pour échanger sur les
avancées et l'engagement de la
collectivité en matière de transition
énergétique
quyen collagiste 77-77 collège
tous les collèges de la réunion seront
en autoconsommation à la base d'énergie
photovoltaïque avec une solution de
stockage
le bond en avant sera fait espace
naturel sensible
c'est une compétence reconnue de par la
loi pour le conseil départemental
chacun doit faire un peu mais il faut
donner de la cohérence dans les actions
faites par les uns et par les autres
vous avez bien sûr l'état
vous avez la région les
intercommunalités des opérateurs
économiques
et puis bien sûr le département mais il
faut que tout ce monde là travaillent
ensemble mieux travailler ensemble pour
réussir un beau projet de développement
durable pour notre île le bonus de cette
semaine c'est un rendez vous à ne pas
manquer samedi prochain le 16 juin aura
lieu le 25è championnat régional
d'orthographe et le 15e concours de
calcul rapide
vous pourrez suivre la dictée en direct
sur le facebook du département à partir
de 13 ans
[Musique]